so I have a question though about Elon
buying Twitter
when Elon initially tried to back out my
theory was he gets in to some of the
nitty gritty and sees national security
letters or some kind of government
roadblock something jamming up the
system and then he's like okay I can't
buy this but then of course they're like
no you have to buy it now I wonder if he
saw signs before buying it that this is
how bad it was I mean he just said that
on Twitter he said it was destined for
bankruptcy by May so but the FBI
involvement well of course I mean this
is this is what we're talking about
right so we talk tie together what you
know Luke was saying what Steve is
saying what's happening is that they are
we are unleashing with with the power of
social media with a power of
communication for us to be able to talk
have these shows listen we are
unleashing a second flame of the
Enlightenment throughout the west and
these frauds know they're going to get
deposed they know they're going to get
exposed they know they're going to be
seen and they know they're going to be
in all kinds of trouble for the crimes
that they've been committing so Elon
Musk steps into Twitter wants to buy
this thing and all of a sudden they're
like oh
we've been running a we've been running
a Scion yeah an active measure that's
right this is this is this isn't even
like controlled opposition kind of
language this is an active measure that
was being waged against the country and
what people don't understand is what
we're dealing with is literally called
unconventional warfare we're deep deep
into an unconventional War this is why
memes are so powerful as stupid as that
sounds because it disrupts I agree it
disrupts that's right but this is why
the FBI specifically went after memes
they went after satire exactly they went
after people who were making jokes
because they know that's and uh that's
al-basinski even talks about this when
it comes through and your enemy but I
want to add to bannon's point really
quick here because I believe that the
U.S intelligency had a coup d'etat when
they took out JFK 100 they had Vietnam
they had the CIA dosing people with acid
they sparked the cultural revolution
some people think it was the libertarian
ideas that sparked Revolution no it was
too much government doing too many
things acting too crazy acting like it
was the emperor that spurred to cultural
revolution which the intelligence
agencies have been writing on the back
of with promoting degeneracy trying to
destroy the family unit a part of their
larger depopulation agenda but that's
just my two cents a lot there it's 100
101 and expanding an Empire we don't
want an Empire our Founders didn't want
an Empire we fought remember the British
Empire was just about to head to the top
of its game with India and the British
East India Company our Founders said we
don't want to be a part of that we don't
want an oligarchy running us and we
don't want to land an aristocracy
running us and we're prepared to go to
war and sacrifice Our Lives to do that
to fight that you know that's what we
have to do today because that's what
they've built and that's what they're
trying to protect one problem I'm having
is that the House of Representatives is
sort of an oligarchy unfortunately
they're bribable and I wonder if we
could build like a system of
decentralized you know smart contracts
where everyone could represent their
unit like all 700 000 of us from a
district could vote yes or no on
something and then that'll go to the
Senate we still have the Senate DeVito
The Crazy mob but do we really need this
vulnerability I'm on a roll and you're
going blockchain on me
no no no let me say no the founder set
it up so that the the House of
Representatives is always there we
should be winning House Seats we should
have dominant control of the house right
we should adopt and make it and make it
the weapon make it remember the founders
gave it the ability to taxes
Appropriations War all of it is with the
people they wanted that is the closest
thing in this Republic and everybody in
this audience left and right should come
together populist nationalists should
come together and say take a stand and
say no more we've seen what he did to
Kennedy to Nixon even now to Trump and
they're going to do it with it if Bernie
Sanders got in there they do the same
exact thing to Bernie Sanders this is a
little a little wild you know Ian and
Luke both bring up JFK but we just saw
that report from Tucker Carlson where he
said he talked to a source the cia's and
the CIA was involved they told him with
the assassination of JFK do you think
that they were involved with Robert
Kennedy's assassination also obviously
duh Luke's just like Let It All Out
do you trust the government Ian sorry
sorry I don't trust anybody Luke that's
why I want to decide that's why I like
smart contracts because if we're voting
for ours if we're representing ourselves
we don't have to rely on one guy to tell
tell someone what 700 000 of us think it
doesn't make sense I don't trust that
guy
speak up so we got a silent moment I can
go deep into some weird philosophy thing
instead of like this
specific crap I don't understand
no I do I want to talk about what Steve
just said because I don't think enough
Americans understand what America is
about we can talk about voting schemes
and you know policy [ __ ] and all this we
want what we want I don't think most
Americans understand what America is
about and Steve actually just touched on
it and the key thing is that America is
founded on a single important key
principle is that not one of us is God
yes that's the key principle of this
country so what that means if we're not
God
true Authority lies in God whether you
believe in God or not you take it as a
symbol or as a literal thing doesn't
matter true Authority lies in God you're
not God therefore you don't have any
true authority over any other man and
now we have our Anarchist friend like
nodding along of course
therefore what are we going to do we're
going to set up a system where we lend
political Authority with restrictions
with time limits with all kinds of uh
balanced divided Powers so that they
can't run amok so that we don't become
an Empire because we're not God it's
that simple and if you don't understand
the basis of this what's John Locke
what's he saying John Locke says well we
got to secure life liberty and property
why does he say that Thomas Jefferson
Echoes it in the Declaration life
liberty Pursuit of Happiness why do they
say this they say this because if they
can't kill you they can't lock you up
and they can't take your property then
they can't control how you think and
they can't control how you believe and
they can't control how you worship God
and that's what it means to be a free
human being but they can control the
food supply and the water sources and we
need to make sure that we have
decentralized food and water as well
obviously I mean then we're getting into
Kissinger oh my God I didn't realize you
know whoever controls the food controls
the region vote controls the the energy
controls the nation whoever controls the
money controls the world yeah yeah are
you uh do you believe in God are you
atheist I am an agnostic is the fan
fancy word of the day but but let me say
this I I rail against secularism all the
time and James and I had this
conversation yesterday and I think
secularism is a threat to the west but a
much greater threat than not believing
in God is believing you are God
and that is a much more dangerous threat
I will be partners with any atheist or
agnostic even though I'm an Evangelical
bible-believing Christian to fight the
people that believe they are God because
that is a much greater threat than not
being sure if there is a God listen
that's the fight of the West that's the
that's the drama of the entire West
there's these three competing Reigns is
it the rain Realms there's reason
there's Faith then there's this people
who get to believe that they they think
they know everybody they're better
everybody better than everybody they
know everything they have the gnosis the
special knowledge the secret knowledge
the Revelation the plan for the universe
and they get to enact it on us we don't
get to enact our will because we are
stupid and don't know it those people
are the enemy and everybody who knows
that we're not those people are on the
same team well there's another there's
another layer to this that I wanted to
bring up because you know if you guys
don't believe in God you have to
understand the very powerful people in
charge they believe in something there's
a reason they go to the Bohemian Grove
there's a reason they hang out with uh
Marina braver Mitch and do Spirit
cooking there's a reason they hang out
with all these devil worshipers
satanists and they do horrible things on
private islands that we can't even speak
about on the show so there is a
spiritual war happening right now
whether you could deny it or not but
what's happening and it's here and
religion is is a part of that war let's
talk about young people because what
you're what you're all basically saying
is main character syndrome which I think
we're seeing a lot of in Millennials and
some gen Z where people think nothing
outside of me matters I also think to a
certain degree we're seeing this in
every generation and and the way I see
it manifest is when police officers go
to say say there's a a knowledge's drag
event in Texas where they're explicitly
engaging in you know things
inappropriate for kids and I'm I'm
talking about what we just saw in San
Antonio with with simulated sodomy and
things like that there should be no
question that the police would go in
there and say hey you can't do this but
they're not willing to do it and I think
because even for these police officers
many are probably in their 30s or a
little older are like I'm not getting
involved they're gonna get mad at me I'm
gonna get yelled at so it's not just
main character syndrome it's also I'm
I'm not going to risk myself for
whatever this is and if we don't have a
cohesive culture where people are
willing to stand up for each other then
it just falls apart or maybe it already
did I mean this is that unconventional
warfare this is what they do in
unconventional warfare they make these
provocations drag queens are a
provocation it's been an escalating
provocation first they're just dressing
up and kind of somewhat you know careful
dress with their clown makeup groomer
clowns or whatever reading stories next
thing you know Tim and I were talking
about this yesterday next thing you know
they're they're dancing they're grinding
they're sexual dancing they're twerking
the next thing you know they're doing
simulated sex acts in front of children
and they're at the every step of the way
this is what Tim was saying to me
yesterday so this is Tim's credit gets
the credit for this is every step of the
way they're saying no no no it's just
this no no it's just this Escalade
escalate Escalade this is an
unconventional warfare tactic to provoke
the goal you guys remember George Floyd
the goal is to have drag Floyd
and I'm serious this is deadly serious
Dave Chappelle speaks about this all the
time especially when it comes to
addressing actors in drag but it even
goes bigger because Balenciaga was not
an accident what was happening there was
a deliberate escalation of the culture
war of them bragging how far they could
take it I agree I agree the West was
largely built on a Biblical principle
and James agrees on distinctions a
distinction between God and man a
distinction between man and nature a
distinction between adult and child the
Bible at its best is a book of
distinctions understanding your place in
the world America understood this it's
why we're the freest greatest country
ever to exist in the history of the
world everything the deconstructionists
are trying to do right now from Citizen
and police officer to rule of law versus
Anarchy is to destroy distinctions
especially when it comes to children
they do not believe that there should be
any different treatment when it comes to
Children sexually or biologically
medically they must destroy the
distinctions this is part of their
theological really screwed up view what
is the defender of a distinction a
courageous citizen it's up for us to say
no no we are going to have the
distinction between an adult and a child
we are going to have the distinction
between God and Men we are going to have
a distinction
in fact that's what keeps us free thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time